Hello.
So the last couple of videos,
well we've been doing a lot of
projectile motion, and
we'll keep doing
some projectile motion.
But I think it may have seemed
more confusing than it really
is, because I kept everything
in terms of variables.
And we worked with the formulas
and the variables.
What I want to do is take all
those things that hopefully
I've taught you or you've had
exposure to over the last
couple of videos, and just do a
bunch of problems. Because I
think this is all about
experience and getting the
intuition and just checking
through a lot of problems.
So let's just do a
straightforward one, kind of
going back to the ball
throwing game.
So let's say I throw a ball
straight up, throw a ball up,
and that the total time the ball
is in the air is, I don't
know, let's say it's
7 seconds.
So how fast did I throw
it straight up?
Not throw up.
How fast did I throw
the ball up?
And then how high did it go?
We've figured out a bunch of
formulas, and we could plug it
straight into those formula and
solve this problem in 10
seconds, or probably more
like 2 seconds.
But what I want to do is just
actually go through the same
logic we went through to get
the formulas, but I'll work
with the numbers.
And I'll show you this isn't
something where you even have
to memorize formulas.
So it took 7 seconds, right?
The ball took 7 seconds to go
all the way up and then to go
down, right?
And assuming no air resistance,
it took the same
amount of time to go
to its peak as it
took to go down, right?
So it took 3.5 seconds
to go up.
Time is 3.5 seconds.
And then it took another
3.5 seconds to go
down, right, 3.5.
So it took 3.5 seconds to
get to its peak, so what
does that tell me?
Well it tells me that in 3.5
seconds, the ball went from
whatever the initial velocity
it was when it left my hand.
The ball went from-- v sub i is
equal to whatever-- it went
from that initial velocity.
This is the ball.
This isn't a number.
And then by the time it got to
the top, to kind of the peak
of its travel, it got
to 0 velocity.
So I'll call that v sub f
or the final velocity.
It went from whatever
speed I threw it
at to 0 in 3.5 seconds.
So now we could just use,
I mean we don't even
have to use a formula.
We could think of
it intuitively.
How fast am I decelerating?
So I'm decelerating at the
rate of gravity, right?
And we know that cause that's
what's slowing down the ball.
So we know that acceleration
is equal to minus 10 meters
per second squared.
And so what do we do?
Well acceleration is the same
thing as a change in velocity.
Acceleration times time
is the same thing as
the change in velocity.
Or the change in velocity
divided by time is
acceleration.
So let's say that.
It's a change in velocity.
Well the change in velocity is
equal to the final velocity
minus the initial velocity.
And that equals acceleration
times time.
So minus 10 meters per second
squared-- I'll stick with the
units this time-- times time.
So it did that in 3-1/2 seconds,
times 3.5 seconds.
So this seconds cancels out with
one of the seconds in the
denominator here.
So I get minus vi is equal to
minus 350 meters per second
minus 10 times, no, that's
3.5, not 35.
So it's minus 35 meters
per second.
Something was looking
suspicious.
Minus 35 meters per second, and
then of course, multiply
both sides by negative 1.
And the initial velocity is
equal to 35 meters per second.
That wasn't too bad.
You don't even have to really
do it formally like this.
You could just say well I'm
throwing it at some speed.
Of the total time, it takes
half of that time
for it go to 0, right?
So I threw it at some speed and
it took 3-1/2 seconds to
go to 0, and it's decelerating
at this speed, right?
So every second it's getting 10
meters per second slower.
Every second I go,
it's getting 10
meters per second slower.
So if it took 3-1/2 seconds to
go to 0, I must have started
off at 35 meters per second.
If that confuses you, use the
formula, but I want to give
you a sense that you can
kind of just use
your intuition, right?
Every second it travels in the
air, it's getting 10 meters
per second slower.
It took 3-1/2 seconds to go from
whatever speed you threw
it at to 0, so it must have
started off at 35 meters per
second, right?
At t equals 1, it was going
25 meters per second.
At t equals 2, it was going
15 meters per second.
At t equals 3, the ball is going
straight up at 5 meters
per second.
And at t equals 3.5, the
ball is stationary.
It's right at the top
and then it starts
decelerating downwards.
Let's do some more problems.
I don't like these colors.
Let me switch to something
nicer.
Also in that problem, I didn't
figure out how high the ball
went, so once again the total
travel time is 7 seconds.
We know the acceleration
is minus 10
meters per second squared.
And we know that the initial
velocity now-- we figured it
out-- is 35 meters per second.
So to figure out how high
it went, so let's
just draw that part.
So the ball is going
up, right?
And we figured out just in its
upward portion to go from vi
is equal to 35 meters per second
to, let's call this vf,
is equal to 0 meters
per second.
It took the ball 3.5 seconds,
right, because this is half of
its travel time.
And then it took another 3.5
seconds to come straight down.
Well we could just use our
fairly straightforward formula
that change in distance is equal
to the average velocity
times time, right?
And this should be pretty
intuitive to you.
This shouldn't even be
viewed as a formula.
Hopefully, it's starting
to be viewed as
maybe even common sense.
So what was the average
velocity?
The average velocity is just
the average of your initial
velocity and your velocity
at the top of the curve.
So that's 0.
So the average of 35 and 0 is
just 35 divided by 2, so it
equals 35 over 2.
And then what's the time?
3.5 seconds.
And I could use my trusty
calculator, provided by Windows.
35 divided by 2 times 3.5 is
equal to 61.25 meters.
It's pretty easy.
So hopefully you're realizing
that we used a lot of formulas
and things.
And the formulas were getting
all over the page last time.
But when you actually do it with
numbers, it's not so bad.
In the next video now, I'm going
to just keep doing a
bunch more problems, because I
think you're probably tired of
this ball throwing business.
I'll see you soon.